la séance est
ouverte l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion sur la procédure d'examen
simplifié en application de l'article
103 du règlement de deux projets de loi
autorisant l'approbation de convention
et accords internationaux ces textes
n'ayant fait l'objet d'aucun amendement
je mets directement au voix chacun
d'entre eux alors sur le premier texte
l'accord entre le Gouvernement de la
République française et le gouvernement
de la Principauté d'Andor concernant la
démarcation et l'entretien de la
frontière qui est
pour qui est contre il est adopté le
deuxème porte sur la convention
d'entraite judiciaire en matière pénale
entre le Gouvernement de la République
française et le gouvernement de la
République de Maurice et la convention
d'extradition entre le Gouvernement de
la République française et le
gouvernement de la République de Maurice
qui est
pour qui est contre il est
adopté l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion prèengagement de la procédure
accélérée de la proposition de loi
visant à prolonger en 2024 l'utilisation
des titres restaurants pour des achats
de produits alimentairire non
directement consommable la parole est à
Madame alenor babo rapporteur de la
commission des affaires économiques pour
[Applaudissements]
minutes merci monsieur
tout à
fait merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre chers
collègues mardi dernier la commission
des affaires économiques a adopté de
manière conforme la proposition de loi
qui vous est soumise ici et qui vise à
proroger l'extension du périmètre des
titres restaurants à l'alimentation du
quotidien dans les grandes et moyennes
surfaces cette mesure a été votée par le
Sénat est définitivement adopté dans la
loi du 16 août 2022 portant mesure
d'urgence pour la protection du pouvoir
d'achat la version initiale de la mesure
prévoyait une extinction de celle-ci fin
2023 suite aux auditions que nous avons
mené je vous propose de conserver cette
menesure cette mesure pour l'année 2024
pour les raisons
suivantes l'objectif de cette mesure est
simple permettre au 5,5 millions de
salariés bénéficiaires de conserver
cette facilité d'utilisation pour leur
aliment
du quotidien dans un contexte
d'inflation
élevée en effet si l'inflation ralentit
que les prix de certaines matières
première commence à baisser et que nous
pouvons entrevoir une baisse potentielle
des prix en rayon l'inflation cumulée
depuis plus de 2 ans pèse encore
lourdement sur le pouvoir d'achat des
Français ceci étant dit je tiens à
rappeler le véritable objet du titre
restaurant sa seule fonction est de
permettre aux salariés de se nourrir
correctement sur leur lieu et leur temps
de travail en l'absence d'une offre de
restauration collective mise en place
par
l'employeur lors des auditions que nous
avons mené l'ensemble des acteurs
s'accordaient à dire qu'il ne faut pas
dénaturer l'objet social du titre les
associations de consommateur et
l'ensemble des syndicats représentés au
sein de la Commission nationale des
titres restaurants souhaite un autre
dispositif répondant de manière plus
fléchée à l'enjeu de la précarité
alimentaire L de la commission le
gouvernement s'est engagé à travailler
sur une réforme du titre restaurant en
saisissant le Parlement en milieu
d'année 2024 c'est pour cela que nous
avons proposé une dérogation d'un
an plusieurs groupes ont déposé des
amendements tendant à proroger
d'avantage ou à péréniser le
dispositif si cela était voté je tiens à
vous alerter sur le risque d'une remise
en question du titre restaurant
pourquoi tout simplement parce que cette
ressource supplémentaire est cofinancé
par l'employeur et soutenu par l'État au
titre d'une meilleure alimentation dans
le travail au bénéfice du salarié il ne
rest serait donc pas étonnant de voir
apparaître une remise en cause du
financement de ce titre ainsi dévoyé de
sa vocation
initiale par ailleurs le titre
restaurant n'est pas nécessairement le
meilleur outil pour lutter contre la
précarité alimentaire dans la mesure où
le dispositif ne permet pas de cibler
les plus modestes les bénéficiaires des
titres restaurants peuvent être aussi
bien ou
que cadrees
supérieurs par ailleurs il est ressorti
des auditions que des solutions
alternatives existaient dans d'autres
pays et notamment en Belgique où existe
également un titre restaurant mais aussi
un cchèque ou un écochèque destiné à
promouvoir l'économie
circulaire aussi chers collègues je
pense que nous avons que nous devons
davantage nous attacher à définir le
meilleur outil pour soutenir les
Français qui en ont le plus besoin
plutôt que de déformer un titre
existant c'est un outil qui nécessitera
d'importantes réflexions pour qu'il soit
à la fois simple efficace bien ciblé et
équilibré sur le plan des finances
publiques au-delà des questions de
dénaturation et de périnisation du titre
nous devons également mesurer les
conséquences sur nos restaurateurs et
commerce de
bouche en effet depuis août 2022 ces 500
millions d'euros perdus au profit de la
grande distribution c'est une perte
d'autant plus considérable que les
titres restaurants représentent 15 % du
chiffre de affire de la restauration
quand il représente seulement 1 % pour
la grande
distribution pour toutes ces raisons je
suis persuadé que cette prorogation
d'une année et d'une année seulement est
la solution la plus équilibrée pour les
salariés et nos TPE PME je vous
remercie merci Madame la
rapporteur la parole est à Madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre délégué chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du
tourisme
bonjour madame la Présidente ouais je
suis un peu malade mais ça
va merci Madame c'est
gentil madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président casbariant Madame la
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
députés nul besoin de vous dire que
cette proposition de loi est attendue
vous le savez par des millions de
Français qui chaque jour plébiscite cet
objet social depuis près de 60 ans le
titre restaurant ce titre spécial de
paiement c'est un avantage social
accordé aux salariés auxquels sont
associés des avantages fiscaux et
sociaux qui bénéficient d'ailleurs tant
aux salariés qu'aux employeurs son
objectif original il est simple
contribuer au repas du salarié qui ne
disposait pas dans son entreprise d'une
cantine ou d'un local aménagé à
proximité de son lieu de travail et à ce
titre l'État se mobilise en exonérant de
cotisation sociale la participation de
l'employeur et d'impôt sur le revenu
celle du salarié pour un peu plus de 1,5
milliards d'euros le titre restaurant
est utilisé en France par plus de 5
millions de salariés et en pratique
parlons-nous franchement par leur
familles l'usage aujourd'hui dévoyé du
titre a évolué soit par la pratique des
uns et des autres avec un usage plus
souple le fait de pouvoir le donner à un
de ses enfants par exemple soit par la
loi et c'est justement cet
assouplissement légal qui fait
aujourd'hui débat depuis quelques années
le titre restaurant s'était déjà adapté
aux différentes crises que nous avons
traversé pour rappel je pense en
particulier au confinement qui a conduit
à doubler le plafond quotidien
d'utilisation le faisant passer de 19 à
38 € durant cette période puis après
être revenu à 19 € à l'issue du
confinement ce plafond journaliste a été
ajusté de façon pérenne à 25 €. l'été
dernier vous avez voté une mesure
permettant d'assouplir
exceptionnellement l'utilisation du
titre restaurant il s'agissait comme l'a
rappelé la rapporteur d'un amendement de
la sénatrice Frédérique puissa sénatrice
LR amendement permettant d'élargir la
liste des produits éligibles à des
produits non consommables immédiatement
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2023 autrement dit
depuis le 1er octobre 2022 le salarié
peut acheter outre les denrées
directement consommables qu'il pouvait
déjà acheté je le rappelle dont les
fruits et légumes d'autres aliments
comme des pâtes ou du riz qu'ils peuvent
ainsi cuisiner eux-mêmes et ramener au
bureau le lendemain ce coup de pouce a
été utile apprécié pour de nombreux
salariés français en particulier les
plus précaires avec la forte inflation
alimentaire subie depuis 2022 il a aussi
été utile pour de nombreux Français qui
préféraient grâce à cette souplesse se
cuisiner déplates chez UV pour les
apporter le lendemain sur leur lieu de
travail ou tout simplement aussi pour
déjeûer chez eux en
télétravail au 31 décembre 2023 cette
mesure devait se terminer et j'ai
indiqué publiquement la semaine il y a
une dizaine de jours maintenant la
volonté du gouvernement de prolonger ce
dispositif parce qu'en effet notre
résolution pour protéger les Français
dans cette période reste inchanger notre
objectif est clair prolonger pour une
année une mesure clébicité par des
millions de Français afin de leur
permettre de continuer à acheter des
produits alimentaires du quotidien tant
que l'inflation alimentaire est
importante même si je le rappelle elle
continue de refluer depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant parmi d'autres
dispositifs que le gouvernement prolonge
c'est un outil que nous voulons encore
laisser à la disposition des Français
dans la lutte pour le pouvoir d'achat
que nous livrons du reste ne rien faire
suite été à l'encontre des nombreux
Français qui se sont d'ailleurs exprimés
et qui se sont émus de la disparition
d'un usage élargi certes des
dérrogatoire et dont d'ailleurs ils
ignorait pour beaucoup qu'il était
temporaire aussi le gouvernement
assume-t-il un franc soutien à cette
proposition de loi pour terminer si je
n'ai pas entendu de voix politique
s'élever contre le principe d'un
prolongement pour une année j'entends
les voix qui s'élèvent contre la
pérénisation de cette disposition sur ce
sujet comme sur toutes les évolutions de
structure du titre restaurant je vous
invite je nous invite à prendre le temps
de la réflexion nécessaire et surtout de
la concertation comme je l'ai rappelé en
commission et à ne pas légiférer dans la
précipitation pour graver dans le marbre
une évolution sur laquelle les
principaux intéressés n'ont à cette
heure pas été suffisamment consultés on
a d'ailleurs trop souvent reproché à
notre majorité de ne pas écouter
suffisamment les corps intermédiaires et
je pense s'agissant à la base d'un sujet
de dialogue social je le rappelle qu'il
conviendrait d'élaborer en pleine
concertation avec eux la réforme plus
structurante du titre restaurant que
j'appelle de mes vœux je pense en
particulier aux représentants des
partenaires sociaux qui siègent à la
commission nationale Mame la ministre à
la parole qui si je pense en particulier
aux représentants des partenaires
sociaux qui siège à la commission
nationale des titres restaurants je
pense au MEDEF à la CPME à l'UDP du côté
des employeurs comme vous le savez mais
il ne faut pas non plus oublier du côté
des salariés qui sont partie prenant du
financement du titre restaurant la CFDT
la CGT la CFTC FO et CFE CGC cette
réforme je l'ai déjà annoncé aux
partenaires sociaux et aux représentants
du secteur de la restauration et des
commerçants depuis désormais plus d'un
mois la question de la pérenisation
devra être regarder mais dans ce cadre
dans le cadre d'une réforme plus
structurelle des titres restaurants avec
la concertation et la l'aval des
principaux partenaires sociaux que je
viens de mentionner tout comme
d'ailleurs la dématérialisation que j'ai
annoncé ou encore la manière de
développer les dons aux associations
d'aide alimentair l'urgence est comme
souvent pas toujours la meilleur
conseillère ces questions nécessiteront
des échanges nourris avec les principaux
intéressés aussi je souhaite que ce
texte issu de la commission des affaires
économiques n'envisage que l'extension
temporaire qui se justifie pleinement
pour des causes exceptionnelles et que
les discussions sur la pérénisation de
la mesure a lieu dans le cadre des
travaux que j'ai lancé sur la réforme
structur des titres restaurant et dont
je vous garantis qu'elle sera menée tout
au long du premier semestre 2024 je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est maintenant à monsieur
Guillaume casbarion président de la
commission des affaires économiques et
pour 5
minutes madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues bonjour à toutes et à tous le
le problème est assez
simple tout le monde connaît les tickets
resto puisque nous avons dans notre pays
plus de 5 millions de bénéficiaires 5
millions 4 qui tous les jours des
travailleurs des salariés qui
bénéficient de tickets restaurant qui
leur permettent généralement donc
d'aller déjeuner d'aller parfois
effectivement utiliser ces tickets resto
pour des plats préparés et donc se
nourrir dans le cadre de leur travail il
se trouve que en août dernier nous avons
voté à l'initiative des sénateurs et
nous l'avons voté à l'initiative d'une
sénatrice LR une dérogation qui permet
de façon temporaire d'utiliser ces
titres restaurants pour aller acheter
des aliments des courses alimentaires
non préparer je pense par exemple aux
pâtes au riz à des produits secs qui
peuvent servir à des préparations à la
maison faire des tuperwar éventuellement
quand on télétravail cuisiner le midi
mais en tout cas c'est un usage élargi
que nous avons décidé de voter en 2022
de façon temporaire et parce qu'il y
avait une question d'inflation et de
pouvoir d'achat qui se posait de façon
très importante avec une inflation
importante en 2022 cette dérogation elle
arrive à terme le 31 décembre de cette
année on est le 23 novembre il reste
très très peu de temps pour agir si nous
ne faisons rien le 1er janvier les 5
millions d'utilisateurs de ticket resto
ne pourront plus utiliser ce ticket pour
pouvoir aller faire des courses
alimentaires en supermarché en superette
avec des produits secs non préparés et
c'est pour ça que dans l'urgence c'est
vrai et parce que probablement peu de
personnes avaient vu que cette
dérogation arrivait à terme j'ai
souhaité j'ai déposé en avec monsieur
marcangéi monsieur Mayard monsieur
matthi et tous les députés de la
majorité une proposition de loi qui est
très simple qui vise à dire nous
proposons de prolonger pendant un an
cette dérogation que nous avions mise en
place en août 2022 de sorte que nous ne
mettions pas dans la difficulté des
salariés au 1er janvier
2023 2024 et donc c'est l'objectif très
simple de cette proposition de loi
décaler d'un an cette dérogation pour ne
pas mettre en difficulté les gens au 1er
janvier et euh je crois que nous sommes
sur la même ligne avec les sénateurs
nous avons cette volonté commune et je
crois qu'en commission aucun groupe
aucun groupe n'a souhaité s'opposer
fermement à cette disposition euh tout
le monde a globalement validé l'idée
qu'il fallait prolonger pour mettre les
Français en difficulté euh voilà donc
mais très bien mais donc euh j'entends
que LFI ou d'autres groupes disent on
l'avait vu avant les autres vous avez
une niche qui est prévue ce mois-ci vous
l'aviez pas déposé vous l'aviez pas
déposé dans votre niche bon le groupe RN
non plus ne l'avait pas déposé sur sa
niche bon donc je pense que tout le
monde peut avoir l'humilité nécessaire
de dire que oui s'il vous plaît ni
gouvernement ni
majorité nit vu qu'il y avait cette
dérogation qui arrivé à terme le 31
décembre de cette année il y a pas
besoin de s'énerver tout le monde était
d'accord en commission après j'entends
qu'il peut y avoir tous les groupes
auront la parole après il peut y avoir
une volonté de certains groupes d'aller
un cramp plus loin et de se dire pour
certains est-ce que c'est pas 2 ans
plutôt qu'un an et est-ce que il faut
pérenniser
définitivement définitivement cette
possibilité d'acheter des produits
alimentaires avec ces tickets restaurant
là ça a été très bien dit par à la fois
madame la ministre et Madame la
rapporteur on a deux sujets le premier
c'est que le temps presse et qu'il faut
qu'on soit d'accord avec les sénateurs
si nous modifions le texte je ne sais
pas garantir que nous ayons un vote
conforme avec les sénateurs et que nous
puissions aller vite or je vous l'ai dit
nous devons légiférer avant le 31
décembre de cette année donc il y a un
enjeu à être court simple et à se mettre
d'accord très vite avec nos collègues
sénateurs deuxème problème de modifier
le texte c'est-à-dire d'élargir encore
cette dérogation ou de la pérenniser
c'est que comme l'a dit la ministre il y
a besoin d'avoir une concertation
parceque les tickets resto ne tombent
pas du ciel ça fait l'objet d'une
concertation avec les organisations
professionnelles les organisations
syndicales et qu'on ne peut pas sur un
coin de table prendre des décisions
structurantes et définitives sur un
sujet qui a vocation à concerter les
syndicats les travailleurs les
commerçants les restaurateurs tout tous
autour de la table madame la ministre
vous avez pris un engagement très clair
de concerter au premier semestre pour
peut-être réformer plus structurellement
le titre restaurant l'appeler
différemment envisager un nouvel outil
qui soit plus structurant prenons le
temps de la concertation mais là
aujourd'hui chers collègues l'enjeu que
l'on a est très simple c'est ne pas
mettre les Français en difficulté le 1er
janvier légiférer d'ici le 31 décembre
et faire en sorte que dès le 1er janvier
si des Français souhaitent utiliser
leurs tickets resto pour acheter les
courses alimentaires en supermarché et
bien ils ne soi pas empêché de le faire
et que nous soyons pas responsable de
les empêcher de le faire c'est pour ça
que je vous invite à voter ce texte bien
évidemment comme nous l'avons fait en
commission et dans le strict respect de
ce texte simple sans modification de
sorte que nous puissions aller vite et
répondre aux attentes des Français je
vous remercie merci monsieur le
président alors nous passons maintenant
à la discussion générale et je vais
passer la parole à Monsieur Benjamin
Luca pour le groupe écologiste nupes
pour 5
[Musique]
minutes
je reprends mon
souffle merci Madame la la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers
collègues le passage à la caisse du
supermarché est un véritable calvaire
pour le porte-monnaie de nos
concitoyennes et de nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui un français sur de en vient
à se priver occasionnellement ou
régulièrement d'un pas et chaque jour
nous recevons dans nos permanences des
Françaises et des Français travailleurs
précaires mais pas seulement qui
n'arrivent plus à joindre les debouts
comme l'on dit et qui n'arrivent plus à
se nourrir à nourrir leurs enfants
correctement voilà l'effet de
l'inflation et voilà l'effet de votre
politique d'abandon social depuis
maintenant 6 ans à la tête de
l'État la pauvreté augmente le nombre de
pauvres augmente non chers collègues ce
n'est pas excessif ce sont des
statistiques tout à fait officielle qui
démontre que sous la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron la pauvreté a augmenté
le nombre de pauvres a augmenté le
sentiment de déclassement et pas que le
sentiment d'ailleurs des classes
moyennes à lui augmenté c'est la vérité
des chiffres mais vous pouvez à la
manière d'un Donald Trump lier elle est
là elle est factuelle et elle est
vérifiable par chacune et par chacun
parce que cette inflation plombe
toujours autant le budget des Françaises
et des Français en particulier sur les
denrées alimentaires il nous semble
indispensable de permettre aux salariés
de notre pays de payer une partie de
leurs dépenses aliment avec les titres
restaurants même si nous continuons et
nous continuerons à défendre ici la
hausse des salaires et notamment du SMIC
à 1600 € à défendre la hausse des
minimas sociaux à défendre l'indexation
des salaires sur l'inflation parce qu'il
faut une réponse forte de partage des
richesses qui sont à normalement mal
réparti dans notre pays pour répondre
aujourd'hui aux enjeux de pouvoir
d'achat et à l'exigence d'égalité qui
figure je vous le rappelle chers
collègues dans la devise de notre
République je suis heureux que vous ayez
reculé après avoir exprimé l'INT
intention de revenir sur cette
dérogation parce que les raisons qui ont
présidé à cette mesure n'ont pas disparu
l'inflation est toujours là vous
semblait bien optimiste sur sa
résorption mais elle continuera à être
là et là aussi toutes les études
sérieuses le disent nous plaidons donc
en revanche pour une prolongation à plus
long terme de cette mesure nous avons
déposé un amendement en ce sens désolé
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques les
parlementaires amend sous amende font
leur travail de législateur c'est bien
le moins permettez que pour une fois
comme nous n'avons pas de 493 nous
puissions faire la loi à égalité avec
nos collègues de la majorité c'est un
droit que nous considérons même être un
devoir nous proposons donc de prolonger
cette mesure jusqu'à fin 2024 non pas
jusqu'à fin 2024 mais pour 2 ans jusqu'à
fin 2025 en effet tout laisse à penser
effectivement que l'inflation ne
s'arrêtera pas dans les 12 mois qui
viennent euh et bien que nous soyons en
faveur de la prolongation de cette
mesure nous soulevons tout de même deux
écueils qui nous inquiètent au plus haut
point premier écueil la façon dont nous
examinons ce texte et symptomatique de
la manière qu'à votre gouvernement
d'approcher la gestion des crises
celui-ci est arrivé sur le bureau de
notre assemblée en une semaine à peine
donc monsieur le président de la
commission des finances n dit faut faire
de la président la commission des
affaires économiques nous dit faut faire
vite faut faire vite mais peut-être
faut-il euh faire un peu plus
intelligemment plutôt que l'amateurisme
qui est le vôtre arrivé sur le bureau de
notre assemblée une semaine à peine
preuve de la carence criante en terme de
réflexion sur la crise de l'alimentation
dont vous faites preuve elle n'est pas
née hier elle n'est pas née la semaine
dernière cette crise la crise du pouvoir
d'achat elle est durable considérez-vous
qu'il soit normal qu'un texte soit
présenté en commission puis en séance en
moins d'une semaine avec un délai de
dépôt d'amendement qui se compte en
heure et une consultation de la société
civile réduite à minima ce
fonctionnement ad démocratique n'est
plus possible ici on peut pas faire des
493 tout le temps et surtout il faut
respecter le Parlement et écouter les
partenaires sociaux madame la ministre
l'a dit il y a un instant il va falloir
joindre les actes à la parole
malheureusement c'est loin d'être la
première fois que vous légiférez ainsi
au doigt mouillés avec le couteau sous
la gorge sur des sujets qui ont un
impact direct sur la vie des Françaises
et des Français au mois de juillet nous
avons déjà légiféré en urgence sur la
hausse du plafonnement des loyers vous
semblez à chaque fois être pr de cours
par les échéances comme si vous n'aviez
pas vu venir ni préparer la fin des
mesures de soutien en pouvoir d'achat
quel amateurisme deuxiè écueil et
surtout le plus important vous vous
attaquez mal vous ne vous attaquez
malheureusement pas pardon au problèmes
structurels qui caractérisent le modèle
agricole et le système alimentaire
construit sur une doctrine néolibérale
ces 60 dernières années après le report
des échéances des négociations
commerciales cette proposition de loi
fait l'effet d'un d'une éème rustine
face à la hausse des prix ça tout à voir
chers collègues il est pourtant urgent
aujourd'hui de construire une véritable
réflexion autour de l'accès à une
alimentation saine durable abordable de
qualité qui rémunère justement les
agricultrices et les agriculteurs qui
respectent l'eau l'air les sols le
vivant et le climat pas seulement pour
les salariés mais aussi pour les
personnes privées d'emploi nos jeunes et
nos aînés en ce sens les écologistes et
de nombreuses organisation mène depuis
de nombreuses années une réflexion
autour de la mise en place d'une
sécurité sociale de l'alimentation nous
vous invitons à engager avec nous cette
réflexion enfin le télétravail vient
indéiablement bousculer le dispositif
des titres restaurant cette nouvelle
donnée doit être intégrée à la réflexion
pour envisager un dispositif pérenne de
soutien à l'alimentation des salariés
lorsqu'il travaillent et donc cuisine à
domicile il me reste que 2 secondes j'ai
pas donc le temps de vous parler des
marges et des super profits dans la
grande distribution ce sera donc pour
une prochaine fois je vous remercie mer
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane peu pour le groupe
Gauche démocrate et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
nupes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission madame la rapporteur mes
chers collègues il y a quelques mois
notre assemblée avait fait le choix dans
un contexte marqué par une forte
inflation en particulier sur les
produits alimentaires d'ouvrir la
possibilité d'utiliser les titres
restaurant pour l'achate d'enré
alimentaires non directement consommable
il s'agissait d'une mesure d'urgence
sociale que nous avons plement
pleinement soutenu aujourd'hui la
situation sociale n'a que très peu
changé certes l'inflation alimentaire a
reflué mais reste très élevée atteignant
toujours en octobre 7,7 %. dans ce
contexte tout je dis bien tout doit être
mis en place pour lutter contre la
précarité alimentaire qui ne cesse de
progresser les titres restaurant
constitue un outil discutable à bien des
égards je citerai par exemple que le
marché est aujourd'hui détenu par quatre
grands groupes qui ont été condamnés en
2019 par l'Autorité de la concurrence
pour cette entendu sur les commiss qu'il
s'appliquait et que cette sanction de
l'autorité financière a été confirmée
pas plus tard que la semaine dernière
par la cour d'appel de Paris pour autant
les titres restaurants constituent aussi
un outil immédiatement mobilisable dans
cette perspective nous voterons bien
entendu la prolongation de l'usage des
titres restaurants pour les denrées
alimentaires il s'agit je le répète de
nouveau d'une mesure mesure d'urgence
sociale pour autant inutile de dire que
face à la précarité alimentaire qui
progresse nous ne pouvons pas
perpétuellement répondre par des
bricolages de cet ordre à l'heure de
lancer leur 39e campagne les restos du
cœur lance un nouveau un cri d'alarme
sur la situation lors de la campagne
2022-2023 30 millions du nombre de repas
supplémentaires ont été distribués les
restaux ont ainsi été ont ainsi mesuré
que l'inflation avait conduit à une
hausse de près de 47 % du recours à
l'aide alimentaire dans ce contexte les
restos du cœur ont d'ors et déjà annoncé
qu'il devaient durcir leurs critères
d'accès ce qui conduirait à refuser près
de 150000 personnes qui étaient pourtant
éligibles l'année dernière face à
l'ampleur de la crise sociale
l'extension des tickets restaurant ne
serurait constitué une réponse complète
et satisfaisante il nous faut d'ors et
déjà et la
ministre vient de l'annoncer réfléchir à
d'autres leviers à ces
éventuelles évolution j'ajoute que
l'intersyndical va je crois aujourd'hui
publier une déclaration sur le sujet
avec un certain nombre de propositions
sur les
évolutions possible de son point de vue
des titres restaurants bien entendu vous
la question des salaires reste central
ces derniers ont augmenté de 3,1 en
2021-222
4,6
2022-223 moyenne bien sûr quand dans le
même temps les prix ont augmenté eux
respectivement de 5,4 et de 4 8 les
décrochage des salaires sur l'inflation
est un facteur majeur qui a conduit de
nombreux ménages dans la précarité
alimentaire outre les salaires d'autres
champs doivent aujourd'hui être explorés
celui d'une véritable sécurité sociale
alimentaire financé sur la base des
cotisations patronnal et salarial
constitue une perspective à étudier car
permettant de concilier d'une part les
enjeux budgétaires auxquels font face
les ménages et d'autre part les enjeux
de les enjeux de qualité de
l'alimentation tant pour nos concitoyens
que pour la planète
les dernières études ont en effet montré
que l'inflation avait conduit outre la
baisse de la consommation à une
dégradation de la qualité des denres
alimentaire consommé reconnu comme un
facteur déterminant dans le
déclenchement de certaines pathologies
l'alimentation est aujourd'hui au cœur
de la santé des Français ces éléments
mis en perspective je veux redire en
conclusion que la lutte contre la
précarité alimentaire est un combat
urgent qui doit être mené avec la plus
grande vigueur et ce en lien avec les
enjeux écologiques et de santé publique
la prolongation des titres restaurants
aux achats de d alimentair n'est pas une
réponse satisfaisante mais je crois que
tout le monde en convient mais elle
constitue malgré tout une modeste
réponse dans l'urgence raison pour
laquelle notre groupe soutiendra cette
proposition de loi je vous remerci merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur max
matizin pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre M et territoire et
pour 5
minutes
madame la
présid madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues l'inflation sur les produits
alimentaires est devenu l'un des sujets
majeurs de préoccupation des Français et
à juste titre puisque la hausse des prix
culmine à 18 % en 2
ans nous connaissons les nous en
connaissons les conséquences ce sont des
cadis moins remplis ce sont des produits
de moins bonne qualité consommé ce sont
des repas euh sautés c'est aussi et
surtout des fils qui s'allongent au
resto du cœur et dans les banques d'aide
alimentaires qui ont bien du mal
aujourd'hui les mèes célibataires des
retraités des salariés aux emplois peu
rémunérateurs les étudiants se voient
contraints de solliciter l'aide
alimentaire cette hausse des concerne
tous les tous les profils et touche tous
les territoires dans l'Hexagone comme
dans les autres mèes partout la fin les
besoins progressent et le manque de
politique publique pour ypalier se fait
sentir beaucoup d'annonces ont été
faites pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
des Français mais avec quelle efficacité
d'autant d'autant qu'elles ont été mises
beaucoup beaucoup aux oubliettes dois-je
vous rappeler la fausse bonne idée de la
vente à perte des carburants souv nous
également de l'accord de modération des
marges annoncé par le président de la
République en septembre dernier avant
d'être inré parmi les rares dispositions
mis en place certaines vont dans le bon
sens même si reconnaissons-le elles sont
insuffisantes et leurs effet limités
depuis août 2022 par exemple
l'utilisation d'étiquets restaurant a
été a été étendu à tous les produits
alimentaires cela a permis à certains de
payer leur pâes alimentaire leur riz
leur VI VI encore leur poisson avec ces
titres des salariés ont été on ainsi
limité la charge des coûts alimentaires
devenue trop
onéreuse cette utilisation
dérogatoire devait prendre fin au 1er
janvier 2024 cela a signifieré la fin
d'un coup de pouce salutaire pour de
nombreux Français la présente
proposition de loi propose de proroger
cette disposition pour un an nous y
sommes bien entendu favorables
l'inflation alimentaire a beau être
moins moins importante que l'année
précédente elle reste persistante nos
concitoyens voient bien que les prix
dans les rayons continuent de grimper
les circonstances que justifi qui
justifiaent hier l'élargir le champ
d'utilisation des tickets restaurant se
vérifie encore aujourd'hui alors pour
prolonger d'une année supplémentaire la
possibilité de payer ses courses au
supermarché avec avec des titres
restaurants est une mesure de défense
d'une certaine façon du pouvoir d'achat
une mesure légitime parce que l'urgence
est toujours là nous considérons par
ailleurs qu'il y aurait une aberration à
permettre l'utilisation de ces titres
dans les supermarchés pour des produits
transformés parfois nocifs pour la santé
tout en refusant qu'il permettent
d'acheter dans ces mêmes endroits des
produits plus sains cuisinables à la
maison cela dit nous comprenons les
craintes des restaurateurs le secteur
est Exen après le covid et confinement
qui avait brutalement mis fin à la
fréquentation de ces de leur
établissements il redoute que les titres
restaurant bénéficient désormais
majoritairement à la grande distribution
et les chiffres leur donnent raison
puisquen puisque qu'en 1 an c00 millions
d'euros de titrre restaurant ont été
utilisés en grande surface la grande
distribution a gagné près de 7 point de
part de marché à la à la faveur de cet
élargissement les restaurateurs et les
commerçants assimiler comme les
boulangers ont pour leur part perdu plus
de trois points bref il faut réfléchir
au moyens de soutenir nos petits
commerçants sans perdre de vue l'urgence
du pouvoir d'achat pour nos concitoyens
au vu des circonstances nous avons
considéré que le moins pire des remèdes
était la prolongation de l'utilisation
des tickets restaurant pour les courses
au quotidien pour une durée d'un an
voire 2 ans comme le prévoirait le texte
reste les circonstances dans lesquelles
cette proposition de loi revient sur la
table est sont pour leur part
contestable une fois de plus cette
majorité aura manqué d'anticipation à
peine quelques mois avant la date
d'échéance pour sembl découvrir la fin
de l'utilisation des titres restaurants
pour des achats de produits alimentaires
non directement consommables et que dire
du ministre de l'économie qui a cherché
à se déchausser défausser pardon sur les
sur les parlementaires pourtant et quoi
que vous disiez cette fin était prévue
et annoncée la date de péremption était
inscrite dans la loi relative au pouvoir
d'achat voté par le Parlement en 2022
après quelques remarques après ces
quelques remarques bien sûr nous sommes
favorables monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur à cette à cette
mesure qui permet de favoriser le
pouvoir d'achat des
salariés merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Pascal laberne
pour le groupe naissance et pour 5
minutes
présidente
temps merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
madame la rapporteur le titre restaurant
plus communément appelé ticket
restaurant bénéficie chaque jour à plus
de 5 millions de salariés en France au
moment où l'inflation alimentaire s'est
accéléré à compté de l'été 2022 où le
taux d'inflation était de 6,8 % c'était
en juillet
dernier passé les parlementaires ont
voté une mesure dans le paquet pouvoir
d'achat permettant d'assouplir
provisoirement l'utilisation du titre
restaurant ainsi alors qu'en temps
normal le ticket restaurant ne peut pas
servir à acheter des alimentss d' brut à
l'exception notable des fruits et
légumes la loi dit pouvoir d'achat a
permis pour toute forme de produit la
permis pour toute forme de produits
alimentaires avec un ticket restaurant
bien que l'inflation commence à refluer
elle reste à un niveau
élevé notamment par rapport à juillet
2022 date de l'adoption du projet de loi
pouvoir d'achat c'est pourquoi les
groupes parlementaire de la majorité
Renaissance horizon modem souhaite
prolonger cette disposition pour une une
année supplémentaire j'ai pris
connaissance des abendnements déposés
sur le texte par les groupes
d'opposition certains d'entre vous
souhaitent p péréniser cette disposition
pour ma part j'y suis très défavorable
je voudrais rappeler à tous les députés
ici présents même si nous ne sommes pas
très nombreux ce matin je voudrais
rappeler donc à chacun que ces tickets
restaurant représentaient 15 % du
chiffre d'affaires de la restauration en
2019 péreniser la disposition sans tenir
compte de l'évolution de l'inflation
d'une part mais également des évolutions
sociétales de la façon de consommer de
nos concitoyens reviendrait à condamner
sans doute un secteur le secteur de la
restauration qui a déjà été durement
éprouvé par la crise madame j'ai la
parole vous l'aurez tout à l'heure vous
pourrez utiliser votre temps de parole
on n'est pas très nombreux je pense
qu'on peut aujourd'hui s'écouter dans la
sérénité par des changements d'habitude
qui ont résulté donc de la crise covid
et donc ce secteur souffre actuellement
d'une moinre fréquentation dû à la perte
de pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens je
rappelle par ailleurs que le titre
restaurant est un avantage social ça a
été rappelé tout à l'heure par Madame la
Ministre qui résulte du dialogue dans
chaque entreprise entre les salariés et
les employeurs qui le qu'il finance ce
ticket restaurant au même titre que
l'État je pense qu'une décision de
pérénisation ici dans notre dans notre
hémicycle euh reviendrait finalement à
manquer de correction vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires sociaux ça nous est sans
doute suffisamment reproché pour que le
jour où on le fait je dirais de façon
extrêmement concertée ça puisse mettre
être mis à notre crédit donc je ne pense
pas que une telle décision de
prorogation puisse être décidée ici de
façon unilatérale par la représentation
nationale d'autres amendements proposent
de prolonger la mesure de 2 ans et non
d'un an j'en comprends mieux la logique
chacun aucun d'entre nous n'a envie de
revenir pour voter une nouvelle
prolongation dans un an toutefois la
ministre s'y est engagée que ce soit en
commission ou ici sur C pour euh mettre
en place la réforme du titre restaurant
en 2024 et notamment à l'occasion de sa
dématérialisation personnellement je
pense que cette réforme doit aussi être
l'occasion d'aborder la question de
l'incitation à une consommation de
produits bio dans un cadre de circuit
court plus généralement la logique qui
consiste à permettre l'achat de produits
transformés au détriment de produits
bruts me semble être une mauvaise idée
c'est l'inverse qu'il faut faire tout en
incluant évidemment les restaurateurs
dans la réflexion pour ne pas les
laisser de côté bien évidemment enfin je
rappelle je voudrais appeler la ministre
à élargir un petit peu le champ de la
réflexion du tickier restaurant
notamment pour les zones rurales qui
sont parfois dépourvus de de de petits
commerces qui pourrai répondre à cet
impératif je sais que ça ne simplifie
pas la tâche mais en tout cas madame la
ministre je sais que vous saurez
répondre positivement à à l'intérêt des
des zones rurales et des petits
commerces dans cette zone dans ces zones
qui souvent sont soutenu par les
collectivités territoriales il faut
également qu'au travers de ce disositif
nous puissions apporter notre
contribution et notre
soutien merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Victor Catau pour
le rassemblement national et pour 5
minutes madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de
commission madame la rapporteur mes
chers collègues aujourd'hui le
gouvernement dans un revirement des plus
surprenants nous sollicite pour vit
l'extension d'une mesure qu'il
critiquait il y a à peine une semaine
l'utilisation des tickets restaurants
pour les courses alimentaires un
changement de cap causé par le té
politique médiatique et social qui a
provoqué l'annonce de la fin de cette
mesure mais également par le dépôt de
l'excellente proposition de loi de notre
collègue Thomas ménager face à la grande
populaire et à celle du rassemblement
national le gouvernement n'a eu d'autre
choix que de revenir sur sa décision
nous sommes ici pour débattre d'une
question essentielle qui qui touche
directement le cœur et la table des
Français la prolongation de
l'utilisation des titres restaurants
jusqu'en 2024 une question essentielle
alors que la France connaît aujourd'hui
l'inflation alimentaire la plus élevée
d'Europe que plus de 15 % des Français
déclarent ne pas pouvoir manger à leur
fin et qu'un Français sur deux saute au
moins un repas par jour aborder ce sujet
ce n'est pas qu'évoquer des
problématiques liées à la restauration
et aux grandes surfaces c'est aussi
aborder avant toute chose la
problématique la plus importante et la
plus pesante pour les Français celle du
pouvoir d'achat en 2022 le gouvernement
avait introduit cette mesure dans le
cadre de la loi pouvoir d'achat et
celle-ci était perçue comme une réponse
immédiate à la crise qui frappait notre
pays nous sommes toujours un an plus
tard dans la même situation l'inflation
est toujours là et avec elle la
souffrance la souffrance de nos
concitoyens face à l'érosion continue de
leur pouvoir d'achat ce gouvernement est
passé mettre dans l'art de la réaction
mais semble impuissant dans celui de
l'anticipation nous ne pouvons accepter
que nous législateurs soyons réduits à
voter continuellement des mesures d'urg
au lieu de construire des réformes
substantielles et durables pour répondre
efficacement à la crise actuelle il est
temps de reconnaître que les solutions
temporaires visant à résoudre les
problèmes chroniques ne suffisent plus
les Français méritent mieux ils ne
demandent pas l'omone mais juste de
vivre décemment au rassemblement
national nous croyons fermement la
nécessité de réformes audacieuses et
nous proposons d'ailleurs pour cela des
mesures concrètes nous proposons
notamment de supprimer la TVA sur les
produits de première nécessité afin de
permettre aux Français des plus
précaires d'accéder aux produits
essentiels de la vie le Portugal l'a
fait et il est aujourd'hui le pays avec
le taux d'inflation alimentaire le plus
bas d'Europe mais au rassemblé nationale
nous avons surtout des mesures en lien
avec le salaire nous vous avions proposé
l'année dernière notre proposition de
loi visant à exonérer de les charges
patronales les augmentations de salaires
de 10 % ce qui aurait constitué une
solution viable pour améliorer le la
rémunération des salariés sans pour
autant alimenter la spirale
inflationniste une mesure en faveur des
Français une mesure que vous avez refusé
au rassemblement national nous
souhaitons avant tout augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat des Français et leur
permettre d'utiliser le le fruit de leur
travail comme ils l'entendent et non
comme vous le souhaitez par ces
politiques désastreuses le gouvernement
appauvrit les Français et les montte les
un contre les autres la semaine dernière
il a ainsi cherché à opposer les les
salariés contre les
restaurateurs nous sommes bien
évidemment d'accord sur la nécessité
d'aider nos restaurateurs qui sont des
acteurs essentiels de notre économie
cependant nous refusons cette logique
d'opposition et de confrontation nous
pensons que c'est en renforçant le
pouvoir d'achat des Français que nous
encouragerons les Français à retourner
au restaurant et leur permettant ainsi
de renoué avec le plaisir de la
gastronomie en soutenant cette
proposition de loi aujourd'hui nous
répondons au cris de détresse de ceux
pour qui bouclé la fin de mois est
devenu un véritable calvaire nous
répondons aux malêes des millions de
Français qui n'en peuvent plus de
réglementation inutile imposé par le
gouvernement nous répondons à la
souffrance de nos concitoyens qui ont
chaque jour du mal à se nourrir à
s'habiller et à se loger dans la dignité
mais nous avons conscience que cette
mesure ne constitue qu'un pansement
temporaire sur un mal bien plus grand et
plus profond nous avons conscience que
nous devons inspirer à plus qu'il est de
notre devoir d'aller au-delà des
réponses immédiates et de construire un
avenir plus prospère équitable et
durable pour les Français un avenir où
chaque citoyen peut vivre dignement et
se nourrir décemment alors même si ce
texte ne répond que très partiellement à
la problématique de pouvoir d'achat qui
touche nos compatriotes nous voterons en
faveur de ce dernier pour que les
Français puissent un peu respirer je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame sopia Chikirou
pour le groupe la France insoumise N
c'est pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes bonjour prés bonjour madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur monsieur
le Président collègues en juillet 2022
le gouvernement promettait aux Français
une loi d'urgence pour protéger leur
pouvoir d'achat 18 mois après où en
sommes-nous nous en sommes ù de la lutte
contre l'inflation et ben on va prendre
trois exemples le prix des primes
d'assurances et des cotisations
mutuelles hausse de 6 à 12 % pour les
assurances auto 8 % pour la santé 6 à 7
% pour l'assurance habitation en juillet
2022 je vous disais il faut bloquer les
prix des primes d'assurance vous me
disiez non et qu'avez-vous fait pour
lutter contre l'inflation de la des
primes d'assurance par exemple Bruno a
demandé et Bruno c'est couché qui paye
les citoyens qui encaisse les assureurs
7,3 milliards de bénéfices pour Axa
résultat opérationnel en hausse de 18 %
au premier semestre 2023 allez on prend
un 2uxè exemple l'énergie l'électricité
première haose à 15 % 2e Haos à 15 % 3e
Haos à 15 % qu'a fait Bruno Le Maire il
a supplié Bruno a évidemment céd qui
payent les citoyens qui encaissent total
énergie plus 28 % de Bénéfic nets en
2022 pour établir un nouveau record à 19
milliards d'euros alors venons-en à prix
de l'alimentation de la nourriture le
prix de l'assiette la sienne celle de
ses enfants hausse encore 20 % sur un an
30 % sur les produits laitiers la viande
le poisson 30 % madame la ministre vous
entendez qu'a fait Bruno Le Maire il a
pointé du doigt les industriels qui
pourrai faire mieux il a demander la
répercussion de la baisse des prix
immédiatement et devinez quoi Bruno
cause toujours qui paye les citoyens qui
encaisse Carrefour plus 26 % de Bénéfic
en 2022 ah bon allez pardon excusez-moi
ce matin je m'embal un petit peu j'ai
été un peu injuste Bruno Le Maire
éternel ministre de l'économie ministre
d'État messieurs dames écrivain de
talent mais économiste de
pacoti il avait pris quand même une
grande mesures pour les Français avec
les tickets restaurant il a dit alors
c'est pas pour tous les salariés hein
c'est 5 millions 18,5 % des salariés qui
sont concernés par les tickets
restaurants alors la macronie l'URA
concédé à ces 5 millions de salariés de
pouvoir utiliser leurs tickets
restaurant pour acheter des produits
alimentaires non directement consommable
c'est impressionnant et je suis
impressionné hein pas de la mesure mais
de de votre culot vous parvenez à nous
présenter cette mesure comme un cadeau
social un effort du gouvernement alors
que ce sont les salariés eux-mêmes qui
payent leurs tickets restaurant à 50 %
c'est leur argent c'est une mesure qui
profite aux parents au patron pardon et
qui leur permet de pas payer de
cotisation sociale et employeurs et en
plus c'est une mesure qui est présentée
comme un coup de pouce à la consommation
populaire alors qu'elle profite d'abord
à la grande distribution et nuit
pénalise les artisans de la restauration
le maximum de la générosité de
l'idéologie néolibérale je veux rétablir
un fait les tickets restaurants ne sont
pas un cadeau ce n'est pas de l'argent
gratuit c'est tout simplement une
subvention à l'employeur de la moitié
des repas des salariés en échange
d'exonération sociale et fiscal première
vérité à rétablir la seconde vous êtes
tellement soucieux du sort des salariés
que vous aviez oublié que cette mesure
s'arrêta au au 31 décembre 2023 vous
avez oublié les salariés leur pouvoir d'
chat il a fallu que le Sénat vous le
rappelle il a fallu que ce soit les
parlementaires qui déposent à plusieurs
reprises cette proposition de loi non
seulement vous oubliez tout le temps les
salariés mais madame la rapporteur vous
nous dites en discussion générale mais
si on y pense au salariés on a fait la
prime Macron la prime de la valeur
ajoutée ah bon vous savez combien ça
concerne de salariés 16 % vous savez
quelle est la moyenne de la prime Macron
800 € même pas 80 € par mois vous nous
dites ensuite on a fait la hausse du
SMIC au passage automatique et qui à
toujours un temps de retard sur
l'inflation ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
sur les bass salaires la hausse de leur
salaire est trois fois moins rapide que
celle de l'inflation enfin vous nous
dites on a fait la revalorisation des
minimas sociaux 1,6 % en avril 2023
quand on a une inflation à 5 %. en somme
vous ne faites rien pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français et on en vient donc
à cette mesure pérenisé un dispositif
qui ne peut en aucun cas s'assimiler à
une politique alimentaire c'est c'est
tout simplement une permission pour les
salariés de pouvoir faire des courses
avec des tickets restaurants il faut se
battre pour que cette permission puisse
avoir lieu alors on va la voter parce
qu'on ne veut pas pénaliser les salariés
vous dites il faut réfléchir nous on
vous dit une chose ce qu'il faut faire
c'est encadrer les commissions des
entreprises monopolistiques sur les
tickets resto des commissions qui sont
passées de 1 % à 5 % les salariés leurs
famillees vont pouvoir encore quelques
temps faire des courses avec leur ticket
resto des courses qui coûtent toujours
plus cher vraiment vous n'êtes pas à la
hauteur merci madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur thibaau Bazin pour
les républicains pour 5
minutes merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le Président
de la Commission des Affaires économique
madame la rapporteur mes chers collègues
nous sommes rassemblés aujourd'hui pour
prolonger jusqu'au 31 décembre 20 24
l'utilisation des titres restaurants
pour des achats de produits alimentaires
non directement consommables depuis le
1er octobre 2022 et jusqu'au 31 décembre
2023 conformément à l'article 6 de la
loi pour la protection du pouvoir
d'achat les titres restaurant peuvent
être utilisés pour acquiter la totalité
ou une partie du prix de tout produit
alimentaire qu'il soit ou non
directement consommable il est essentiel
de rappeler ici comme vous l'avez fait
madame la ministre et monsieur le
Président de la Commission que cette
mesure d'élargissement temporaire a été
initialement introduite par les
sénateurs républicains à l'été 2022 lors
de l'examen du projet de loi mentionné
c'était une réponse pragmatique à
l'escalade de l'inflation et à la
flambée des prix de l'énergie elle a
ainsi permis aux travailleurs de
maintenir un certain pouvoir d'achat en
2023 malmené en ces temps d'incertitude
économique en raison aussi des risques
épidémique et du télétravail nous leur
avons ainsi permis d'élargir à
l'ensemble de l'alimentation les achats
au moyens de ces tickets cela profite
ainsi à leur pouvoir d'achat il coûte
toujours moins cher de préparer un repas
à la maison que de l'acheter tout près
malheureusement sans modification du
calendrier ce serait fini le 31 décembre
2023 sur la temporalité de la mesure
elle reposait sur l'anticipation d'une
décru de l'inflation tout en envisageant
la possibilité que nos citoyens n'aient
plus besoin de s'accrocher à ce
dispositif fin 2023 la réalité est que
l'inflation continue de sévir
aujourd'hui hélas rendant impératif le
renouvellement de cette mesure car
l'inflation va malheureusement encore
perdurer en 2024 même si elle va baisser
la Banque de France a révisé à la hausse
à 2,8 % sa prévision d'inflation tandis
que l' FCE l'estime à 3,3 %. je m'étonne
que Bruno Le Maire par voie de presse le
15 novembre dernier se soit rejet la
paternité du dispositif prétendant que
le gouvernement et non le Parlement
souhaitait le prolonger face à cette
affirmation trompeuse du ministre de
l'économie rappelons qu'aucune
initiative gouvernementale n'est à faire
valoir en la matière dans le projet de
loi de finance pour 2024 cette tentative
de réécriture de l'histoire témoigne ou
d'une mauvaise fois d'une réticence ou
d'une incapacité à engager des mesures
concrètes et durables pour améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat des Français qui
travaillent en témoigne la l'absence
totale de réforme structurelles pour
élever le niveau de vie des Français à
savoir la réduction des dépenses de
l'État à même de baisser les charges qui
pèsent sur les Français qui travaillent
la situation actuelle marquée par
d'importants défis économiques exige
plus que jamais de continuer à soutenir
le pouvoir d'achat des familles
françaises qui travaillent pendant cette
période difficile la prolongation
jusqu'à fin 2024 et l'élargissement de
l'utilisation des titres restaurant est
ainsi une musière de justice sociale en
ces temps qui court cependant nous
sommes conscients que pérenniser cette
mesure pourrait avoir un impact négatif
sur le secteur de la restauration les
titres restaurants sont à l'origine
conçus non seulement pour cofinancer le
repas des salariés qui n'ont pas d'offre
à leur travail mais aussi pour soutenir
les commerces de proximité une
utilisation étendue permanente
risquerait ainsi détourner une part
significative de la clientèle des
restaurants affectant ainsi leur chiffre
d'affaires en prolongeant
l'élargissement de manière temporaire
nous offrons un soutien nécessaire au
français tout en préservant l'équilibre
économique du secteur de la restauration
C approche temporaire se veut une
réponse adaptée à la situation actuelle
tout en tenant compte des implications
futures cela doit demeurer une
disposition ponctuelle et limité dans le
temps la réalité c'est que cette mesure
que les républicains souhaitent
renouveler pour une nouvelle année est
un soulagement financier pour de
nombreux Français qui travaillent cela
étant dit cette mesure demure incomplète
puisqu'elle ne concerne pas un nombre
significatif de travailleurs en effet
actuellement seul 5,5 millions de
salariés sur les 28 millions que compte
notre pays ont accès à ce dispositif
soulignant ainsi l'ampleur de la lacune
à comblée il faudra y travailler de plus
nous pourrions étendre notre vision de
soutien des Français qui travaillent
au-delà de l'alimentation quotidienne je
pense notamment au frais d'essence dans
nos territoire mais ce n'est pas la
vocation des territoires des titres
restaurants qu'il ne faut pas dévoyer
malgré ces manquements la prorogation de
cette mesure est nécessaire notre devoir
envers les Français prévaut c'est donc
avec la ferme conviction de défendre le
pouvoir d'achat que notre groupe des
Républicains s'engage à soutenir cette
proposition de loi dans sa rédaction
actuelle car il s'agit bien là d'une
initiative parlementaire qu'il faut
saluer et je remercie nos collègues de
l'avoir déposé et porté aussi mes chers
collègues c'est dans cette optique que
je vous invite à considérer vous aussi
avec la plus grande attention et
bienveillance la prolongation d'une
année supplémentaire de cette mesure
j'espère vraiment que nous voterons
unanimement pour ce texte dans l'intérêt
de nos concitoyens en visant et
j'insiste un vote conforme car il y a
urgence merci monsieur le député la
parole est à monsieur Éric martinau pour
le groupe démocrate pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues nous sommes appelés ce jour à
examiner la la proposition de loi visant
à prolonger en 2024 l'utilisation des
titres restaurants pour des achats de
produits alimentaires non directement
consommable comme par exemple le lait
les œufs le riz la farine et cetera
comme l'ont rappelé mes collègues et
Madame la reporteur cher annlor ces
titres restaurant avaient pour objectif
initial de contribuer au repas du
salarié qui ne disposait pas dans son
entreprise d'une cantine ou d'un local
aménagé
à proximité de son lieu de travail or
cette volonté initiale a été amenée à
évoluer en raison de la hausse des prix
des produits alimentaires rappelons-le
cette inflation importante procède à la
fois de la vive reprise économique suite
aux différentes vagues de l'épidémie de
coronavirus puis de la guerre menée à
l'encontre de l'Ukraine face à cette
hausse des prix des denrées alimentaires
qu'elles soi brut ou transformé il
apparaissait nécessaire de permettre
l'utilisation des titres restaurants
pour acheter des produits non
directement consommables à préparer et à
cuisiner c'est ce qui a été fait au
travers de l'initiative de notre
collègue au Sénat mais cette mesure
devait prendre fin au 31 décembre 2023
ainsi trois facteurs principaux portent
notre groupe à soutenir la proposition
de loi visant à prolonger d'un an cette
mesure exceptionnelle le premier même si
l'inflation sur les produits
alimentaires diminue progressivement
elle reste supérieure au Hauses de
salaire constaté le deuxième le
développement du télétravail et sa
pérénisation entraîne aussi une
utilisation des titres restaurant pour
cuisiner chez soi par exemple sur la
plage du
déjeuner il convient dès lors de prendre
en considération la situation de ces
millions de salariés nous notons
d'ailleurs que de nombreux salariés
désormais préparent leur repas à leur
domicile et l'amène sur le lieu de
travail le dernier cuisiner chez soi est
essentiel pour la qualité nutritionnelle
de nos assiettes autant que pour la
baisse du prix du CAD de course en outre
l'alimentation est forcément moins
transformée et donc elle est bien dans
ses des cas nettement supérieurs et
meilleurs pour la santé cela étant dit
au-delà de la conjoncture inflationniste
il apparaît à notre groupe que cette
disposition ne devra pas être pérénisée
au-delà du 31 décembre
2024 à moyen terme il sera indispensable
de réfléchir aux mesures à adopter afin
de soutenir le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens sans porter préjudice au
restaurant les restaurants sont les
poumons économiques de nos villes et
villages lieux de socialisation et
défenseur de notre patrimoine
gastronomique que nous soutenons en
parallèle nous tenons à souligner qu'une
piste de travail existe déjà avec un
ciblage des dispositifs d'aide à
l'alimentation sur les produits locaux
et de qualité correspondant ainsi à
notre objectif de soutenir nos
agriculteurs et à améliorer en même
temps la qualité des assiettes de
chacune et de chacun notre groupe
démocrate votera pour cette proposition
de loi pour 2024 je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Marie Noël madame
Marie Noël btistel pour le groupe
socialiste et
apparenté
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues
il y a quelques mois nous nous
retrouvions ici en catastrophe pour
adopter une proposition de loi de notre
ancien collègue Thomas casaznav pour
prolonger le plafonnement de l'indice de
révision des loyers locatifs et
commerciaux AF afin d'éviter un choc qui
aurait amplifié la crise inflationniste
et social actuel c'est un peu le même
mode aujourd'hui où nous devons prologer
en urgence un autre dispositif de
pouvoir d'achat qui arrive à échéance
cette fin d'année nous aurions préféré
madame la ministre une anticipation un
travail sur l'adaptation de ce
dispositif sur le long terme sans
oublier la destination première
d'étickets restaurant en soutien au
restaurateurs que l'on réoriente vers
une aide alimentaire nécessaire dans un
contexte de précarité grandissance et
nous n'oublions pas non plus que tous
les salariés ne bénéficient pas des
titres restaurants en octobre 2023 selon
l'INC les prix des produits alimentaires
et boissons vendu en grande distribution
sont en hausse de 8,8 % sur 1 an c'est
les derniers ont vu un ralentissement
voire un tassement de l'inflation sur
ces produits aucune stabilisation n'est
encore intervenue et encore moins une
correction à la baisse permettant de
retrouver des niveaux de prix conformes
au cous réel des denrées brutes ce taux
cache par ailleurs de grandes disparités
depuis janvier 2022 les prix de la
viande ont ainsi augmenté de 20,1 % et
n'ont connu leur premier tassement qu'en
septembre 2023 d'autres produits comme
le riz ont connu des Hauses encore plus
importante de 31 % sur 1 an de plus
l'évolution des salaires sur la période
demeure largement inférieure avec une
évolution de l'indice du salaire mensuel
de base de seulement 4,6 %. ainsi les
conditions économiques et sociales qui
ont motié et justifier cette mesure
demeure actuelle et justifie une
prolongation non seulement d'une année
supplémentaire mais même de 2 années
jusque fin 2025 en effet ce n'est qu'à
cette échéance que les prévisions
macroéconomi omique du gouvernement donc
les vôtres envisagent un retour à la
normale de l'inflation et un debit de
correction sur les prix et les salaires
du secteur privé de plus ce délai
permettra de donner d'emblé de la
visibilité aux bénéficiaires et aux
acteurs économiques plutôt que de
revenir dans les mêmes conditions à
l'automne 2024 pour une nouvelle courte
prolongation madame la ministre vous
avez dit en commission qu'une
prolongation de 2 ans était prématurée
du fait du chantier que vous avez engagé
à avec les professionnels sur une
profonde de cet outil vous nous l'avez
rappelé ici ce matin et vous avez
rappelé votre engagement pour faire
aboutir ce chantier que nous soutenons
d'ailleurs car si nous souhaitons
étendre cette prolongation à titre
exceptionnel et transitoire pour 2 ans
les titres restaurant n'ont pas vocation
à devenir d'échec
alimentaire mais vous nous accordez
qu'une telle concertation
avec les partenaires pourrai être longue
et complexe en outre nous connaissons la
forte volatilité du calendrier
législatif qui pourrait empêcher que le
produit de ce chantier puisse trouver
une traduction législative avant fin
2024 ainsi madame la ministre nous vous
proposons par précaution de prolonger
d'emblé de 2 ans cette dérogation avec
comme présupposer le fait que si votre
chantier devait aboutir d'ici là bien
évidemment nous pourrions y mettre fin
avant fin 2025 même avant fin 2024 si
vous parvenez à un accord dès lors que
l'outil serait refondu ou d'ailleurs que
d'autres seraiitcé créé ce que nous
souhaitons puisque je l'ai dit en
préambule le titre restaurant n'a pas
vocation à devenir une aide alimentaire
il faut une un dispositif dont puisse
bénéficier l'ensemble des salariés ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui donc ça
notre position nous semble une position
éclairée et raisonnable mais en tout
état de cause considérant l'urgence
sociale notre groupe votera comme en
commission pour cette proposition de loi
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Paul Christophe pour le groupe
horizon et apparenté pour 5
minutes madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues le titre restaurant a
aujourd'hui 67 ans et bénéficie
directement à plus de 5 millions de
salariés sans compter leur famille qui
ne disposent pas d'une cantine ou d'un
local aménagé à proximité du lieu de
travail cet avantage social est cher aux
Français à ce titre l'État se mobilise
en exonérant de cotisation sociale la
participation de l'employeur pour
environ 1,5 milliards d'euros chaque
année depuis 2017 l'engagement de la
majorité présidentielle a été entier
pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
Français à l'image du titre au
restaurant qui s'est adapté aux crises
exceptionnelles que nous avons traversé
en effet la hausse des prix des produits
alimentaires d à la fois la vive reprise
économique ce qui a suivi la crise du
covid-19 et à l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie nous a amené à faire
évoluer ce dispositif en responsabilité
à l'été 2022 au moment où l'inflation
s'est accélérée de manière importante et
atteint plus de 6,8 % nous avons voté
une mesure dans le paquet pouvoir
d'achat permettant d'assouplir
provisoirement l'utilisation du titre
restaurant alors que l'inflation
alimentaire est encore présente en
France et même un niveau supérieur à
celui de l'été 2022 il est normal que la
question de la prolongation d'un an de
ce dispositif se pose le groupe horizon
y est favorable et soutiendra toujours
les mesures utiles et plébiscitées par
des millions de Français il nous semble
ainsi essentiel de permettre aux
Français d'acheter à la fois des
produits directement consommables comme
des denrées à cuisiner par ailleurs nous
sommes conscients des difficultés des
restaurateurs pour qui cette mesure
n'est pas simple dans un contexte où il
souhaite pouvoir retrouver les flux de
consommation antérieurs à la crise
sanitaire non nombre d'entre nous ont
déjà constaté des fermetures de commerce
en particulier de restaurants faute de
reprise d'une activité normale après la
crise sanitaire qui peut pour partie
s'expliquer par un changement des
comportements alimentaires compte tenu
du recours accru au télétravail à cela
s'ajoute les normes contraignantees
complexe et de plus en plus dense qui
pèse sur nos restaurateurs et qui
implique des investissements lourds que
beaucoup ne peuvent effectuer je
constate en effet lors de mes
déplacements dans ma circonscription qui
est à la fois urbaine rurbaine et rurale
à tel point ce problème est réel et
pousse les restaurateurs à mettre la clé
sous la porte c'est pourquoi je ne
souhaite pas que nous laissions croire
que la prolongation de l'utilisation des
titres restaurants pour des achats de
produits alimentaires non directement
consommables serait seul à l'origine des
difficultés du secteur devons aussi
prendre en considération l'aspiration à
davantage de flexibilité pour les
Français qui rencontrent des difficultés
financières notamment dans le contexte
d'inflation actuelle mais souhait aussi
mieux maîtriser leur alimentation cette
mesure doit donc être adoptée rapidement
afin que les supermarchés ne soient pas
contraints de refuser lesticket
restaurant dès le 1er janvier
2024 le groupe Horizon est toutefois
favorable à l'évolution de ce dispositif
et soutient votre souhait madame la
ministre de porter une réforme d'ampleur
sur le titre restaurant nous devons être
fi de cet héritage français qui a réussi
à s'exporter largement ces dernières
années rappelons que le plafond
journalier d'utilisation des titres
restaurant est passé à 25 € le 1er
janvier 2022 octobre 2022 et est monté
jusqu'à 38 € lors de la crise sanitaire
néanmoins la majorité des dispositions
qui l'encadre remonte à
1967 il nous faut ainsi entamer une
réflexion globale sur ce dispositif pour
s'adapter notamment au changement des
modes de consommation à cet égard l'un
des points importants de cette réforme
structurelle annoncé par le gouvernement
concerne la dématérialisation
dématérialisation totale du titre qui
permettrait à de nouveaux acteurs de
rentrer plus FA facilement sur le marché
c'est une bonne nouvelle à l'heure où
environ 55 % du marché utilise des
titres
dématérialisés par ailleurs il est
important de réunir l'ensemble des
parties prenantes dans la refonde du
dispositif en échangeant avec les
représentants des employeurs qui
représente 60 % du dispositif et les
serliers qui en financent 40 %. c'est ce
que prévoit le gouvernement et je tiens
à saluer cette volonté de concertation
large le groupe horizon et apparenté est
favorable à cette proposition de loi je
vous
merci merci monsieur le
député euh alors je ne vois pas le
dernier orateur donc la discussion
générale est maintenant close et je vais
suspendre la séance pour 2
minutes j'appelle maintenant dans le
texte de la commission l'article unique
de la proposition de loi alors j'ai un
inscrit à l'article monsieur Vatin pour
les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président de la
Commission madame la rapporteur euh
quelques mots ici pour remercier le
gouvernement une fois n'est pas à
coutume d'avoir entendu la question
d'actualité que j'ai posé la semaine
dernière sur ce sujet et qui euh
peut-être que vous l'aviez vu avant mais
en tout cas ça vous a fait réagir
puisque la réponse que le ministre m'a
faite et ce que vous avez dit aux médias
quelques heures plus tard était un petit
peu différent en tout cas pour vous
remercier d'avoir entendu euh cette
cette question des titres restaurants et
du du non consommable directement dans
la mesure où euh de très nombreux
salariés modestes sont dans l'incapacité
d'utiliser des tickets restaurants au au
restaurant justement même si les
restaurateurs protestent parce que il
faut toujours rajouter un petit peu
d'argent sur le ticket restaurant et
c'est extrêmement difficile pour
beaucoup de gens d'aller tous les jours
rajouter 4 ou 5 € sur un ticket repas on
sait tous que de faire le repas à la
maison et de venir avec sa gamelle au
travail coûtera moins cher on le
constate tous quand on est un petit peu
attentif au salariés qui nous entourent
il y a pas qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
bien partout dans nos circonscriptions
nous pouvons le le constater alors je
pense évidemment au restaurateurs aussi
mais je pense que je pense aussi que
l'inflation est bien supérieure à la
difficulté des restaurateurs aujourd'hui
pour tous les salariés modestes et même
si cette disposition est provisoire dans
l'immédiat
la vocation à être adapté à être modifié
de sorte que chacun puisse s'y retrouver
mais je pense qu'il faudrait éviter
seulement de privilégier quelque chose
spécifiquement pour les salariés
modestes pour éviter comme d'habitude
les effets de seuil qui font que ceux
qui sont juste au-dessus sont également
victimes d'une discrimination qui n'est
plus acceptable dans notre société on
doit toujours être attentif aux
travailleurs et privilégier ceux qui
travaillent par rapport à ceux qui ne
font rien je vous remercie très bien
merci Monsieur députés alors nous allons
passer aux amendements à l'article je
vous indique sur l'amendement numéro 3
je suis saisie par le groupe socialiste
apparentée d'une demande de scrutin
public que j'annonce dans l'ensemble de
l'Assemblée nationale que sur l'article
unique je suis saisie par le groupe
renaissance d'une demande de scrutin
public que j'annonce dans l'encein de
l'Assemblée nationale et que sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi je
suc par le groupe renaissance d'une
demande de scrutin public que j'annonce
dans l'encein de l'Assemblée nationale
amendement 18 monsieur
Clouet merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente si nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui ici c'est parce que depuis 2
ans les prix de l'alimentation ont
explosé de manière considérable plus 20
% en 2 ans ce qui signifie que là où on
pouvait acheter 5 paquets de pattes il y
a 24 mois on peut plus aujourd'hui en
acheté que 4 avec la même somme dans
cette situation vous avez tout refusé
depuis 2022 la hausse des salaires
refusé l'obligation de révaluer les
minimas de convenion collective pour
monter tous les salaires refuser le
blocage des prix l'encadrement des
marges refusé alors une exception les
titres restaurants pour lesquels vous
avez proposé que pendant un an on puisse
les utiliser pour acheter des produits
non directement consommables
c'est-à-dire de la farine des œufs du
lait bref de quoi se faire à manger chez
soi pour l'amener sur le lieu de travail
et se nourrir on peut manger ainsi pour
moins cher et de manière plus saine
c'est une proposition que nous avons
soutenue même si malheureusement elle
n'est que du
détail là aussi malheureusement pour
vous vous aviez oublié apparemment que
cette loi avait été adoptée en 2022
puisque vous vous réveillez un mois et
demi avant c'est un petit peu tard mais
ça tombe bien pour vous puisque vous
pouvez nous dire pas le temps de
discuter on a que quelques semaines
devant
nousèz parler un tout petit peu moins
fort pour qu'on entende l'orateur merci
merci beauoup sinon je peux parler plus
fort madame la Présidente il y a pas pas
de difficulté pour ça donc vous nous
proposez de repousser pendant un an ce
dispositif exceptionnel et bien nous
proposons ici de le mettre dans le droit
commun afin que nous n'ayons pas l'année
prochaine le même rendez-vous quand vous
aurez à nouveau oublié les propres
textes que vous avez fait adopter et
quelque part c'est une manière de lutter
contre entre vos trous de mémoire et
l'incompétence visible du suivi de vos
propres textes de loi donc nous sommes
ici dans une démarche de coconstruction
épargnez votre temps économisez le nôtre
maintenez le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés bénéficiaires des titres
restaurant soit 5,4 millions de Français
de français adopter cet amendement là et
comme ça et bien vous serez tranquille
ce que vous adoptez aujourd'hui ce que
vous proposez aujourd'hui d'étendre
pendant un an sera Pen dans le droit
pour le bien merci monsieur le député
madame la rapporteur avis de la
commission
mon cher
collègue mon cher collègue en règle
général vous soutenez plutôt les
ouvriers que les cadres supérieurs or le
titre restaurant aujourd'hui répond aux
utilisateurs très largement et je pense
que ce dispositif du titre restaurant ne
doit pas être dénaturé et doit et on
doit travailler sur un dispositif qui
cible uniquement les plus modeste de
fait je seraai défavorable à votre
amendement
merci Madame la Ministre avis du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
je le
redis le titre restaurant est un
avantage social et on on a sur une idée
de la sénatrice LR en 2022 accepter de
déroger à la règle et c'estàdire que
l'exception doit devenir la règle sans
concertation avec les représentants des
partenaires sociaux qui siègent je le
rappelle à la Commission nationale des
titres restaurants et qui il nous semble
indispensable d'intégrer dans cette
refondte et cette réforme non c'est
pourquoi péreniser le dispositif sans
prendre le temps de mobiliser les
partenaires sociaux qui portent côté
employeur et côté salarié l'intégralité
du dispositif ne nous semble pas être la
bonne méthode c'est pourquoi l'avis sera
défavorable je vous
remercie merci Monsieur
cloué merci madame la Présidente alors
vous venez de le dire à l'instant
effectivement les titres restaurants
bénéficient avant tout au cadre
malheureusement les cadres font partie
des victimes de votre politique puisque
c'est le groupe socio-pressionnel qui a
perdu le plus de pouvoir d'achat depuis
2021 et je vois pas pourquoi les rang de
la gauche ne devraient pas défendre
aussi le pouvoir d'achat des cadres et
vous permettre de leur faire les poches
donc ce n'est pas une raison
deuxièmement deuxièmement vous nous
dites il faudrait consulter alors déjà
pour consulter il faut se réveiller à
temps et pas un mois et demi avant c'est
ce que je vous propose de faire cet
amendement comme ça vous aurez tout le
temps de lancer des consultations de
pouvoir réformer à nouveau le code du
travail l'année prochaine bref quelque
part c'est ici épargner du temps à tout
le monde quant au soucis de consultation
il est très dommage que vous vous en
rappeliez 25 jours avant l'expiration du
délai limite pour adopter un texte de
loi et venant de personnes qui n'ont
consulté les syndicats ni le patronat ni
sur la réforme de l'assurance chômage ni
sur les retraites ni sur aucun des
textes concernant le code du travail la
hiérarchie d'énorme le pouvoir d'achat
ça nous laisse un petit peu de marbre
comme argumentaire merci Monsieur Bazin
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de
commission madame la rapporteur mes
chers collègues moi je je crois rêver en
en entendant notre collègue Adrien cloué
parce que non cloué s'il vous plaît
monsieur cloué seul monsieur Bazin a la
parole je crois rêver parce qu'en fait
ça va en contradiction avec un certain
nombre de positions que vous avez pris à
différents moment je pense notamment sur
le nivellement par le bas des des des
salaires et qu'à un moment sur un
certain nombre de disposition je pense
en bof famille où on a justement des
effets de seuil et que parfois les
catégories j'allais dire
socio-pressionnel avec des agents de
maîtrise avec des cadres ont pu être
pénalisés et vous n'avez pas du tout
soutenu les mesures qui allai éviter
qu'il soit pénalisé et donc là
aujourd'hui on est sur une disposition
qui doit être équilibrée qui doit être
équilibrée qui doit être temporaire afin
de pas nevoyer on doit tout tenir à la
fois le soutien au commerce de proximité
je crois je crois que ça ça peut tous
nous rassembler qu'à un moment on puisse
soutenir et qu'on doit aussi soutenir
nos salariés qui bénéficient du titre
restaurant et qui dans le contexte où on
a encore un contexte épidémique où on a
encore un contexte inflationniste on
peut pas espérer et et partir de
l'hypothèse qu'on aura toujours une
inflation importante ce serait très
mauvais pour notre pays et donc
forcément on doit travailler à ce qu'
est moins d'inflation et on peut pas
péreniser comme vous le proposez un tel
dispositif il vaut mieux le corriger et
la oré mais là la mesure telle qu'elle
est il faut la maintenir en l'état et
pas modifier ce qui ce qui est proposé
par ce texte parce que c'est un
équilibre qui est j'allais dire le plus
souhaitable possible à la fois pour le
monde de la restauration et pour les
salariés eux-mêmes merci monsieur le
député madame la
ministre juste rappeler que on est réuni
ce matin pour prolonger un
dispositif tout en nayant la garantie
que le gouvernement l'an prochain va
s'atteler à une réforme structurelle des
titres
restaurant mais quand même quand même je
monsieur Clouet quand on a voté contre
la loi pouvoir d'achat en 2022 qui
portait cette disposition quand on a une
niche quand on a une niche qui arrivait
fin novembre sur laquelle on n'a pas
daigné inscrire ce sujet on évite de
feindre que c'est un sujet majeur pour
un groupe politique je vous
remercie mettre au voix je vais mettre
au voix l'amendement numéro 18 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
je vous indique sur les amendements 1 et
2 je suis saisie par le groupe
rassemblement national d'une demande de
scrutin public que j'annonce dans l'
sein de l'Assemblée nationale alors nous
passons maintenant à des amendements qui
peuvent être soumis à une discussion
commune le 1 qu'il défend monsieur de
l'pin oui monsieur allez-y
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame le rapporteur chers
collègues cet amendement vise à modifier
l'article unique de la proposition de
loi afin de prolonger indéfiniment
l'utilisation des titres restaurants
pour l'achat de produits alimentaires
non directement consommable à empêché
les consommateurs d'utiliser leurs
titres restaurant pour acheter de la
nourriture non directement consommable
n'aura pour effet que de les orienter
vers de la malbouffe selon l'assurance
maladie en 2020 le surpoids concerné 47
% des Français adultes 17 % d'entre eux
étaient même obèses à coup non
négligeable pour l'État lorsque ce
dernier doit prendre en charge les
traitements des pathologies directement
liées à l'obésité tel l'hypertension les
maladies du foie et les maladies rénales
chronique avec la généralisation du
nombre du télétravail nombre de Français
préparent eux-mêmes leurs repas
méridiens à partir de produits non
directement consommable ce qui
représente un gain de pouvoir d'achat
non négligeable je vous remercie et si
vous permettez je défends le suivant qui
qui est un am qui est un amendement de
repli au lieu de prolonger indéfiniment
nous proposons de prolongé de 5 ans je
vous remercie merci monsieur titivoli
nous passons maintenant des amendements
identiques le 3 madame
bâtistel monsieur
Poti merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre madame la rapporteur la
position du groupe socialiste a été
largement exprimée avec talent par Marel
baptistel tout à l'heure nous ne voulons
pas changer la vocation du ticket
restaurant et pas prendre des mesures
éternelles de sa modification nous
rappelons que c'est une mesure à la fois
sociale c'estat sociale entreprise
alimentation et restauration que la
dérogation qui avait été introduite
était bienvenue et qu'il convient de la
prolonger notre proposition elle n'est
pas de le transformer aDVITAM et thmal
en d'un chèque alimentation euh notre
proposition elle est de la prolonger de
2 ans parce que la crise que nous
traversons en terme d'inflation qui
remonte crise sociale autour du covid et
de ses effets puis la crise de
l'inflation liée à la géopolitique et au
phénomènees liés à l'énergie mérite aura
un effet retard extraordinaire sur le
pouvoir d'achat et le pouvoir de vivre
plus largement de nos concitoyens les
plus pauvres on a une augmentation de la
pauvreté qui est signalée par tous les
statistiques aujourd'hui par l'INC avec
des lanceurs d'alertes que sont le
Secours Catholique le Secours populaire
et nous n'imaginons pas que fin 2024 au
31 décembre par miracle les questions de
pouvoir d'achat seront réglé donc notre
proposition elle est pragmatique elle
respecte la vocation initiale du ticket
restaurant elle crée une dérogation pour
2 ans plus adaptée à la situation
actuelle c'est le plaiddoyer que porte
aujourd'hui le groupe socialiste qui me
semble pragmatique et nous sommes
disponibles à vos côtés madame la minist
pour engager une réflexion qui pourrait
porter notamment sur l'universalisation
de son accès au-delà de ceux qui sont
les entreprises les plus privilégié
aujourd'hui et qui en bénéficie sa
vocation universelle pourrait être
pensée comme une réforme systémique pour
plus tard nous sommes disponibles à y
participer mais à court terme c'est
l'accès à l'alimentation pour tous par
le ticket restaurant pour 2 ans c'est le
sens de cet amendement merci merci
monsieur le député le 5 madame
regol ah pardon monsieur Lucas je vous
en prie Mame la présidente merci merci
beaucoup de donner la la parole je me
permets en préembu de dire j'ai trouvé
savoureuse la la leçon qui a été faite
par mameme la rapporteur de lutte des
classes à mon collègue cloué qui me
rappelait ce bon mot Jack Brell dans un
très bon film de Lelouche qui s'appelle
l'aventure c'est l'aventure quand il dit
vous de Marx vous avez soutenu surtout
retenu la notion de capital bref vous
avez fait euh madame la ministre un
premier rétropédalage sur ce sujet après
avoir eu des véléités de suppression de
cette mesure vous avez entendu l'appel
de la raison et c'est tant mieux ça vous
arrive suffisamment rarement pour que
nous soyons amenés à le saluer ici et
nous sommes heureux quand vous prenez de
bonnes décisions même fust-ell prise
sous la contrainte de l'opinion publique
et de la pression d'un certain nombre de
de parlementaires y compris dans vos
rangs nous nous vous proposons de
prolonger également d'un an cette
disposition parce que les raisons qui
président qui président à la prise de
cette décision aujourd'hui dans cette
assemblée ne vont malheureusement pas
changer les prix continuent et vont
continuer à augmenter et nous pensons
qu'il vaut mieux pour le pouvoir d'achat
des França prendre des décisions
maintenant qui s'inscrivent dans la
durée que de gérer comme souvent au
doigts mouillés dans la précipitation
sous la pression d'un sondage d'opinion
ou d'une question au gouvernement nous
pensons que c'est là quelque chose de
beaucoup plus raisonnable évidemment
cela ne n'exclut pas le fait que nous
vous appelons toujours à bloquer les
prix des produits de première nécessité
mesure indispensable aujourd'hui au
pouvoir d'achat des ménages et notamment
des ménages plus modestes et a augmenter
les salaires le SMIC a indexé les
salaires sur l'inflation voilà nous
faisons donc là un amendement
extrêmement raisonnable il faut que les
Françaises et les Français notamment qui
télétravaillent puissent continuer à
utiliser ces tickets restaurant pour
l'alimentation qu'ils utilisent pendant
qu'ils travaillent chez eux qu'ils
cuisinent chez eux et il faut que les
tickets restaurant puisse continuer à
être utilisé pour se nourrir ce n'est
évidemment pas une situation
satisfaisante mais elle est aujourd'hui
indispensable notamment pour palier à
votre inaction en matière de lutte
contre l'inflation et contre la baisse
de pouvoir d'achat des Françaises et des
Français je le rappelle sous ce mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron mercici mon Contin
pvug merci euh le 15 n'est pas défendu
le 19 madame
Chikirou merci madame la Présidente
écoutez pourquoi on est en train de
défendre des amendements sur la
pérénisation en tout cas pour prolonger
encore d'un an de plus ce dispositif
c'est parce que c'est tout ce qu'on a à
se mettre sous la dent hier en
commission on a étudier une proposition
de loi de la France insoumise qui vise à
encadrer les marches de l'industrie
alimentaire parce qu'on sait que ce sont
ces margesl qui sont à l'origine d'une
d'une inflation impossible à vivre pour
nos concitoyen je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est 20 % sur 2 ans d'inflation
sur les produits alimentaires c'est 30 %
sur les produits laitiers et les la
viande et le poisson donc ce qu'on vous
dit c'est soit vous prenez notre loi on
la présentera la semaine prochaine en
niche parlementaire le jeudi soit vous
la votez et là c'est une vraie mesure de
lutte contre l'inflation une vraie
mesure qui va stopper l'augmentation des
prix et pas seulement ralentir et qui va
permettre aux gens d'aller faire leurs
courses avec leur salaire et d'utiliser
leurs tickets restaurant pour manger à
midi au restaurant ou sur leur lieu de
travail soit vous ne le faites pas et
dans ce cas-là il nous reste les tickets
restaurant prolongés pour que les gens
puissent faire leurs courses avec parce
que les gens sont à ce niveau où 25 € de
course avec des tickets resto restaurant
ça leur permet de mieux nourrir toute
leur famille et pas seulement eux sur
leur lieu de travail je tiens aussi à
dire que la moyenne d'étickets
restaurant c'est 7,70 € 7 € 70 ça vous
fait pas un repas à midi hein ça vous
fait au mieux un sandwich donc souvent
il en faut deux des tickets restaurants
enfin vous dites que c'est un avantage
fiscal un avantage social pour les
salariés je vous rappelle que les
salariés payent 50 % de leur ticket
restaurant et je vous rappelle que les
patrons eux récupèent en exénération
sociale et fiscale donc au final qui est
gagnant dans cette affaire le salarié se
croit gagnant parce que un peu d'argent
en plus qui lui permet de se nourrir
c'est pas mal mais les vrais gagnants ce
sont toujours les mêmes donc il faut
aujourd'hui soit vous prenez de vraies
mesures contre l'inflation alimentaire
on vous propose une loi la semaine
prochaine adoptezla et je m'adresse à
tout le monde ici vous êtes un certain
nombre à être d'accord avec cette
proposition de loi pour bloquer les
marches de l'industrie agroalimentaire
merci alors toujours en discussion
commune mais plus parmi les amendements
identiques monsieur Boni le 17
défendu avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur sur ces amendements en
discussion commune
[Musique]
merci madame la
Présidente donc rappelez qu'en août 2022
nous avons voté une mesure d'urgence qui
était liée à l'inflation aujourd'hui les
prix commencent à baisser il faut
laisser les industriels et la grande
distribution
négocier et nous verrons effectivement
ce qu'il en est si nous avons proposé un
an c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement travaille sur la réforme
globale du titre restaurant et qui qu'il
s'est engagé à saisir à nous saisir en
milieu d'année 2024 ce qui donc laisse
9 mois à peu près nous on propose donc
un peu plus d'un an donc c'est largement
pour travailler sur cette réforme de
plus long
terme sur les PME et TPE je tiens à
rappeler que nos restaurateurs et nos
commerces de bouche ont perdu plus de
500 millions d'euros pour les
restaurateurs c'est 15 % de leurs
chiffres contre 1 % pour la GMS
et puisque vous l'évoquiez notamment le
groupe LFI je pense que vous soutenez en
règle générale les TPE et les PME et pas
la GMS donc ce titre est justement un
dispositif pour protéger nos PME
TPE donc voilà je pense que 1 an est
largement suffisant suffisant pour pour
ce ce texte texte très simple et puis je
voulais rajouter pour la niche à F je
pense qu'on aura d'autres textes
puisquil y a une mission gouvernementale
qui va se mettre en place place et nous
aurons de d'autres textes pour parler
des négociations commerciales que d'en
parler là sur un texte de titre
restaurant ou dans le cadre de la niche
la niche LFI sur un texte qui est
inopérant et brutal merci merci Madame
la rapporteur madame la
ministre merci madame la présidente
madame Chikirou vous savez on sait qu'on
déjeunne pas avec un ticker restaurant à
7,60 € on le sait parce qu'on a été
salariier on le sait parce qu'on a été
employeur on sait aussi qu'il y a un
plafond journalier à 25 € et qu'on peut
les cumuler hein madame Chikirou pour ce
qui est des amendements que vous portez
je me suis déjà exprimé sur la
prolongation de la dérogation je
répèterai une chose il y a une seule
chose qui est constante pour paraphraser
Swift c'est votre inconscience votre
inconstance pardon l' lapsus vous quand
même vous proposez quand même de
prolonger un dispositif contre lequel
très majoritairement vous avez voté
contre et que vous n'avez jamais reporté
depuis des semaines vous avez beau jeu
de critiquer les forces politiques ici
présentes ou le gouver gouvernement ni
votre vote ni vos anticipations ne nous
ont étouffé donc franchement un peu
d'humilité dans l'attaque un peu
d'humilité dans l'attaque j'aurais un
avis défavorable sur l'ensemble des
amendements de pérennisation je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre alors
je vais prendre une prise de parole par
groupe monsieur
Bazin merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers
collègu on est sur un dispositif où il y
a eu urgence à l'adopter et pour que on
l'adopte d'ici la fin d'année il faut
l'adopter conforme et il y a un
équilibre à trouver entre les deux
chambres et et donc ce constat il faut
être pragmatique il faut arriver à cet
équilibre et cet équilibre il se base
aussi sur la justification de la
dérogation qui avait été mise en place
sur un contexte inflationniste ce
contexte inflationiste on le voit bien
on aurait pu espérer le contraire mais
l'inflation en 2024 va per perdurer donc
il faut adopter ce texte puisque en 2024
mais qui est capable ici de dire quelle
sera l'inflation en 2025 qui est
capable et certains voudraient même
proroger en 2000 jusqu'en 2028 ça veut
dire qu'on va voir de l'inflation qui va
continuer jusqu'en 2028 je crois que
tous ici au risque de la générer
nousmême ne peut pas se satisfaire d'une
telle situation il faut qu'on reste sur
une disposition temporaire et espérer
comme le font les économistes d'ailleurs
la la banque centrale que ça soit la
Banque de France où ils espèrent une
diminution en 2025 et donc il faut
prendre ce cet élément et puis il y a
surtout moi je suis surpris par ceux qui
disent habituellement soutenir les
commerces de proximité quelle é viiction
on on porterait je pense à ces
restaurateurs il y en a plus de 150000
même peut-être 200000 et je crois que
c'est c'est c'est à mon avis fortement
mal venu de de voter l'ensemble de ces
amendements madame la ministre on
souhaite tous une modernisation des
titres restants vous participez à des
discussions sur avec la commission
national des titres restaurant il serait
intéressant et et je vous demande de
prendre l'engagement devant la
représentation nationale de nous tenir
informé de cette de ces évolutions parce
qu'on le voit bien il y a d'autres
préoccupations que simplement cette
prorrogation c'est l'utilisation même de
de ces titres restant qu'on revienne au
aux ambitions initiales tout en adaptant
aux besoins des salariés donc je vous
demande cet engagement parce que je
pense que il est très important qu'on
puisse aussi accompagner cette
modernisation et pas uniquement se
prononcer sur la question de l'inflation
merci Monsieur Bazin euh monsieur peu
oui merci madame la Présidente euh moi
je suis un peu embêté là parce
que je comprends les bonnes intentions
mais euh je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec les amendements qui
proposent de de prolonger indéfiniment
ni même d'un an supplémentaire pour une
raison
pour une raison qui est assez simple
c'est que même si chaque groupe que nous
sommes nous devons prendre nos positions
en fonction de de nos
convictions sur un sujet comme celui-ci
écouter les organisations représentativ
des salariés me paraît pas totalement
incongru or elles sont les organisations
représentatives des salariés unanime
elles vont l'exprimer dans un courrier
aujourd'hui ou demain unanime pour dire
leur inquiétude sur le prolongement du
ticket restaurant même d'un an parce que
dans les négociations salariales qui
reste la question majeure pour traiter
le sujet du pouvoir d'achat tous les
substituts au salaire il y a pas que les
tickets restants il y a les primes il y
a toute une série de choses mais tous
les substituts au salaire viennent
handicaper à leurs yeux euh les
négociations sur le cœur du sujet qui
est celui du salaire et notamment de son
indexation sur l'inflation c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je je je
souhaite que l'étiquet restaurant soit
progressivement ramené à leur fonction
initiale c'est-à-dire d'aider à payer le
restaurant pour les salariés qui ne
peuvent pas faire autrement ou qui le
souhaitent et que par ailleurs on traite
dans des négociations un la question du
salaire et deux éventuellement la
question de la sécurité sociale
alimentaire du chèque alimentaire de
choses qui permettent d'aider les
salariés notamment les plus modestes à
pouvoir se Nour correctement euh et et
dans des circuits courts si possible
bref il y a toute une série de pistes et
plein de propositions des organisation
syndicale mais je propose que nous ne
mettions pas un croch-pied aux
organisations syndicales des salariés
dans ce processus de négociation merci
Monsieur pe monsieur
Lecamp merci madame la Présidente moi
j'interviendrai je tenais à intervenir
j'avais même déposé un amendement qui
allait un peu dans l'autre sens de ce
qui a été proposé dans dans tous ces
amendements de raccourcir le délai pour
mettre en place une étude sur les sujets
de précarité alimentaire et aller vers
ce qui a été évoqué par mon mon collègue
potier éventuellement une réforme
structurelle du ticket restaurant je
voudrais seulement aller dans le sens de
ce que viens de dire mes trois
prédécesseurs c'està-dire que la
pérénisation c'est la mort du ticket
restaurant le ticket restaurant c'est un
produit qui marchait bien et qui
marchera toujours bien parce qu'il a une
vocation c'est c'est un outil social qui
cofinance un repas de qualité à l'ORS de
pause-déjeuner qui sont de plus en plus
courtes pour les salariés donc faut pas
qu'on revienne dessus il faut qu'on
aille rapidement retrouver sa vocation
première je vourais seulement donner un
chiffre et c'est le chiffre que je que
j'avais envie de d'écrire dans dans mon
amendement c'est que sur la dernière
année c'est les chiffres de tickets
restaurants eux-mêmes et c'est pour ça
que je suis surpris que l'opposition
défende autant cette pérénisation sur la
dernière année les les commerces les
restaurateurs ont ont ont la part de
marché
des restaurateurs dans l'util
l'utilisation du T restaurant a baissé
2,5 % celle des commerces de proximité
de 4 et2 % et dans la dernière année la
principale Corporation qui a gagné sur
l'utilisation du tick restaurant avec
plus 6,5 % c'est la grande distribution
alors je savais pas que l'opposition
défendait autant les intérêts de la
grande distribution mais le péreniser
c'est la mort et je viens d'un milieu
rural des petits restaurants et des
petits commerces en milieu rural qui
assurent avec C restaurant La la
nourriture des des des employés de de de
régions éloignées des supermarchés en
particulier je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député monsieur monsieur
Cato merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le président de
commission madame la rapporteur alors on
parle dans dans cette discussion de de
pérénisation de 2 ans de 5 ans ou même
proroger indéfiniment et la vraie
question c'est effectivement le le
pouvoir d'achat pourquoi on se pose
cette question c'est parce que
aujourd'hui on a un Français sur deux
qui est à 10 € près quand il fait ses
courses et quand on a cette statistique
on se dit que si on prive les Français
qui n'ont plus de moyens pour faire leur
course de ce financement C cette
potentiel ce potentiel financement et
bien on va les priver de se nourrir
dignement et de avec une nourriture de
qualité on parlait tout à l'heure de la
de la ruralité alors je pense que c'est
une une bonne une bonne idée mais la
ruralité aujourd'hui vous avez détruit
la ruralité aujourd'hui dans la ruralité
il n'y a plus de commerce il n'y a plus
de restaurants si les restaurants ont
disparu donc vous allez dire quoi ces
salariés qui travaillent dans la
ruralité qui ont des tickets restaurants
mais qui ne pourront pas les dépenser
dans les restaurants parce qu'ils sont à
30 40 50 km des restaurants les plus
proches ils ne pouront pas évidemment
pas les les les dépenser et donc tout à
l'heure également vous avez opposé et je
pense que c'est pas une bonne solution
les restaurateurs au salariés je pense
que si on veut donner une réponse au
restaurateurs et envoyer les Français
dans les restaurants il faut surtout
parler de pouvoir d'achat et parler
d'augmentation de salaire et ce n'est
pas en privant les Français dans un an
de cette possibilité de payer leur cour
avec avec des tickets restaurants qu'on
va envoyer les Français au restaurant
parce que je suis désolé de vous
l'annoncer mais ils n'ont plus les
moyens d'y aller merci monsieur le
député monsieur
[Applaudissements]
Lucas merci Madame la la Présidente je
souhaitais réagir à au propos de la
rapporteur qui nous dit en somme
rassurez-vous tout ira bien pourquoi
prolonger les prix baissent enfin je
suppose que nous sommes ici nombreux et
nombreux à faire nos courses au
supermarché les Françaises et les
Français les font personne ne constate
une baisse des
prix le passage à la caisse de
supermarché est un calvaire pour le
porte-monnaie de nos consitoyens et nos
concitoyens qui sont à l'euro prês qui
sacrifient des repas ce qu'il
constateent et ce que nous constatons en
revanche c'est que la grande
distribution un certain nombre de
grandes surfaces ont cette pratique
frauduleuse qui consiste à réduire les
quantités vendues tout en maintenant
ou en baissant à peine le prix pour
tromper le consommateur c'est ça que
nous constatons aujourd'hui et face à
cela que vous n'agissez pas et d'un mot
j'entends un collègue qui nous fait le
le reproche d'être soi-disant du côté de
la grande distribution mais qui défend
ici un modèle qui consiste à tuer le
commerce de proximité en construisant en
périphérie de nos villes des immenses
centres commerciaux qui tue l'emploi qui
tue le commerce de proximité qui tue nos
petites villes et nos villages qui
défend ce modèle de société c'est
vous merci Monsieur Lucas la parole est
à Monsieur Clouet
merci madame la Présidente alors la
réponse du gouvernement lorsqu'on
propose de prolonger ce dispositif c'est
ayez confiance bah non on n'est pas dans
le Livre de la Jungle nous n'avons pas
confiance d'abord parce que la confiance
ça se vote n'est-ce pas madamein s'il
vous plaît seul l'orateur à la parole
deuxièmement parce que la confiance ça
se mérite vous nous dites les
restaurateurs les commerçants seraient
victimes des citoyenes et citoyens qui
vont faire leur popotes chez eux et
manger le midi pas du tout ils sont
victimes des commissions à 5 % que leur
prend le acteur totalement cartellisé de
quatre grands monopoles privés dont les
commissions ont explosé parce que vous
leur avez transféré la charge de traiter
eux-mêmes les titres restaurant et ce
avec des restaurateurs restauratrices
qui passent des heures à la fin du mois
à remplir les enveloppes sécurisées une
par acteur du cartel donc la confiance
se mérite troisièmement la confiance
elle se prouve et non nous n'avons pas
spécialement confiance dans vos
promesses lorsque vous promettez que on
va publier les compte-rendus des
doléances au moment des gilets jaunes ce
n'est jamais arrivé un rapport sur deux
que vous promettez dans l'assemblée
n'arrive jamais on est en pleine
discussion sur le PLFSS où sont les
rapports sur la taxe soda le déficit des
épades des exclus du séure le rapport
des équipes mobiles en gériatrie ou la
prestation compensation du handicap la
moitié de ce qu'on vote vous le
respectez pas alors qu'on vote pas
encore moins merci Monsieur cloué
monsieur carvrand
oui merci merci madame la Présidente
l'occasion sur cet amendement de
rappeler peut-être quelques principes de
notre groupe et d'expliquer pourquoi
nous nous voterons contre ces
amendements d'abord parce que nous
croyons que légiférer ça demande de la
mesure et pas de l'outrance ça demande
d'assumer de la complexité et justement
on voit que sur ce sujet il faut du
temps il faut de la
concertation avec les les partenaires
sociaux on l'a déjà porté il y a
quelques jours en retranscrivant
l'accord sur le partage de la valeur on
voit aussi qu'il faut faire attention
aux effets de bord sur la rémunération
du travail et sur le salaire et nous
sommes particulièrement attachés à ce
que le travail pai dans ce groupe et
puis nous sommes attachés à la cohésion
des territoires et quand j'entends mon
collègue dire qu'il n'y a plus de
restaurant en ruralité on doit pas vivre
dans la même dans la même
ruralité et dans le centre de la France
je peux vous assurer qu'il y en a encore
beaucoup et que ces restaurants ils ont
aussi besoin qu'on prenne le temps de
réfléchir à l'avenir des tickets
restaurants comme le soulignait madame
la ministre merci madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente d'abord
monsieur
peu c'est rare malheureusement mais
merci d'avoir rappelé ce que vous avez
rappelé pour ceux qui en douteraient et
qui n'auraient pas eu le temps de
préparer ces
échanges vous pouvez relire par exemple
la prise de parole de la CFDT à l'été
relative à la dérogation que nous avions
voté effectivement l'ensemble à cette
heure des repr représentants syndicaux
des salariés comme du côté des
employeurs appelle à ce qu'on c'est le
titre du communiqué de presse à ce que
le titre restaurant ne soit pas
instrumentalisé donc oui je confirme ce
que vous avez dit et c'est bien pourquoi
il faut qu'on puisse concerter dans les
mois qui viennent à minima puisqu'il
finance comme vous avez été plusieurs à
relever
effectivement que et d'ailleurs
notamment vous monsieur peu dans vot
dans votre prise de parole liminire
les commissions relatives au titre
restaurant avaient été jugé trop élevé
et puis la situation entre guillemets
des quatre opérateurs possiblement
oligopolistiques confirmés en appel il y
a quelques jours je vous confirme que
c'est bien avant l'appel et que je n'ai
pas attendu l'appel pour m'exprimer le 2
octobre dernier en matinale en
l'occurrence sur le sujet de ces
commissions et justifiant l'ouverture
d'une réforme structurelle afin de
baisser et de faire baisser les
commissions sur ces titres restaurants
donc nous n'avons pas attendu que la
Cour d'appel confirme pour ce sisir du
sujet comme vous êtes plusieurs et je
m'en réjouis figurez-vous à me parler de
commerce rural mais aussi de zone
d'activité commerciale saisissez-vous
des nombreux financements qui sont là
qui sont sur la table et qui sont
disponibles peu importe nos couleurs
politique le commerce rural ça fait 6
mois on a ouvert plus de 180 commerces
il y a des appels àoche
12 millions d'euros par an sur 3 ans
pérennisé par la première ministre il y
a plusieurs groupes politiques
extrêmement sensibles à ce sujet majeur
je crois qu'il y a pas de de de clivage
politique à exploiter là-dessus les
appels à projet cour pendant encore 2
ans et demi 10000 compatriotes dans des
communes rurales ont depuis 6 mois
retrouvé des commerces saisissez-vous de
ces appels à projet les financements
sont là et ils sont décaissés au fil de
l'eau et comme vous vous inquiétez des
zones d'activité commercial ce sont 24
millions d'euros qui ont été posés juste
pour cette année pour accompagner
justement au moins une vingtaine de
projets pilotes dans la transformation
de ces zones d'activité commercial pour
les rendre plus adapté moins énergivore
et plus à la hauteur aussi des attentes
de nos concitoyens en matière de
consommation que ce soit le commerce
rural que ce soit le cœur des villes que
ce soit les zones d'activité
commerciales on est là je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre alors
tous les groupes ont pu s'exprimer je
vais mettre au voix ces amendements qui
sont en discussion commune donc
rejoignez vos places sur l'amendement
numéro 1 il y a un scrutin public et il
y a un avis défavorable de la commission
et du gouvernement le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos votant 99 exprimés 97 majorité 49
pour 21 contre 76 l'assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté amendement numéro 2 avis
défavorable commission gouvernement il y
a également un scrutin public le scrutin
est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos votant 92 exprimés 90 majorité 46
pour 13 contre 77 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté sur les amendements
identiques 3 et suivant il y a un avis
défavorable de la Commission et du
gouvernement et il y a également un
scrutin public le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos votant 115 exprimé 114 majorité 58
pour 38 contre 76 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté amendement 17 avis
défavorable commission gouvernement
c'est un scrutin à main levée qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté je vais mettre au voix l'article
unique de la proposition de loi il y a
un scrutin public le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos votant 116 exprimé 115 majorité 58
pour 104 contre 11 l'Assemblée nationale
a
adopté nous passons maintenant à des
amendements sur le titre avec des
amendements pouvant être soumis à une
discussion commune monsieur Lucas le 6
merci madame la Présidente je serai
rapide je profite de cet amendement sur
le le titre pour vous demander madame la
ministre puisque puisque Bruno demande
peut-être que vous pouvez le faire aussi
demander à à la chaîne Lidl d'accepter
l'usage des titres restaurant qui le
refuse jusqu'alors à ses clients il y a
une inégalité de traitement entre les
salariés selon les différentes enseignes
je crois qu'il faut une règle commune et
qu'il faut permettre à celles et ceux
qui font leurs coures chez Lidl de
pouvoir aussi bénéficier du dispositif
qui a été mis en place un certain nombre
de témoignages nous reviennent ces jours
derniers sur cette injustice criante
quant à l'amendement il est parfaitement
exposé expliqué dans l'exposé des motifs
j'imagine que chacune et chacun d'entre
vous en aura pris
connaissance merci monsieur le député
toujours en discussion commune le
4 il est
retiré
madame la rapporteur avis de la
commission sur l'amendement numéro 6
oui merci madame la Présidente je vois
pas le sens fait de cet amendement je
serai défavorable merci Madame la
Ministre j'auraiis un avis défavorable
madame la Présidente merci je vais
mettre au voie l'amendement numéro 6 qui
a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté je vais maintenant mettre au voit
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi qui
fait l'objet d'un scrutin
public le scrutin alors je laisse tout
le monde regagner sa
place le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos votant 119 exprimé 118 majorité 60
pour 117 contre l'Assemblée nationale
adopt prochaine séance cet après-midi à
15h avec la nouvelle lecture du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2024 et la suite de la
proposition de loi pant mesure pour
bâtir la société du bienveillir en
France la séance
élevée